back during the cold war
we had kremlinologists and they studied
everything that they could find pictures
official notices and so forth
to guests about what was happening in
the soviet union
after all it was a closed society had to
really hunt and try to figure things out
well these days i think we need
bidenologists
given that 95 at least of the time biden
and his campaign
are completely closed off to any real
questions or scrutiny
but every once in a while biden emerges
and
immediately starts to reveal his real
agenda
some have said a trump stance is a good
one um to counter
china's influence would you keep the
tariffs
no hey look who said trump's idea is a
good one
we're going after china in the wrong way
well for the entire 24-hour period
that followed that exchange his campaign
and their media allies tried to clean it
all up claiming that biden didn't really
mean
what he said on tariffs that he'd get
rid of them well
a biden aide telling bloomberg yesterday
his position is unchanged
he would re-evaluate the tariffs upon
taking office
he was obviously responding to the
notion that trump's stance is a good one
to counter china's influence
nice try kids as if we didn't hear the
word no in response to the question
of whether he would keep the tariffs now
this is also where bidenology comes in
stay with me here
the day before that disastrous interview
was released
biden's team issued a statement that was
supposedly written by the former vp
himself
and what that means is that the
statement was approved
and vetted by his entire economic team
and it included the following key
passage
trump's phase one trade deal with china
is failing
badly even before the pandemic trump's
go it alone trade war was hammering
american workers small businesses
and farmers well we bidenologists know
that phrase the go it alone trade war
sends
an important signal to the swamp it
means that
biden will not use his authority as
president to impose
tariffs on china and that he'll lift the
tariffs that were imposed by president
trump
furthermore it means that he'll not take
any actions against china
unless they're supported by a
significant block of other countries
which means as a practical matter the
european union
now you see otherwise he would be quote
going it alone
that's exactly what he's saying he won't
do
the europeans are cutting deals left and
right now with china
and they'll never agree to place tariffs
on them period
the obiden obama biden answer to china i
love saying oh biden
back in 2015 was the nightmare tpp the
trans-pacific partnership
and by the way it was so unpopular back
home that even hillary clinton
one of the most committed globalists who
ever lived
said the tpp would kill jobs and she ran
against it
but biden still believes in the tpp
though maybe with a few
face saving tweaks i would not rejoin
the ttp
as it was initially put forward i would
insist that
we renegotiate pieces of that with the
pacific nations that we had
in south america and north america so
that we could bring them together to
hold china accountable oh what gibberish
he can't even get the acronym right
it's tpp joe and i wouldn't pay much
attention to this whole renegotiation
language
the other tpp countries would just say
why would we renegotiate something you
and obama
already agree to and of course they'd be
right
you might see a few little changes here
and there to help biden politically
but then we'd be right back to a big
push to join
the job killing tpp for eight long years
under obama biden administration
american factory workers received
nothing but broken promises
and brazen sellouts and lost jobs during
the course of the next four years we
will bring our pharmaceutical and
medical
supply chains home we're going to bring
them home where they belong
and we'll end reliance on china
the choice could not be clearer you have
a president
in trump who spent real political
capital he got unending grief
in order to get leverage over over china
and he forced them to change their ways
or face being cut out of our markets
altogether
now biden's team has decided to destroy
all of that leverage
and return to the fail failed obama
approach of appeasement in trade policy
now they'll tell you that they intend to
rally the world against china but
their own record shows that they have no
chance of accomplishing that goal
this means a huge win for the ccp
and a huge loss for american workers
across the board
joe biden's entire career has been a
gift
to the chinese communist party and biden
personally led the effort to give china
permanent
most favored nation status as vice
president biden was
a leading advocate of the paris climate
accord
which was unbelievably expensive to our
country
yet one more gift from biden to the
chinese communist party
it's a huge gift now in in short
you got to think about it this way if
you want to go back to the days of
china first america last then biden's
your man
and if you like the idea of china
unchecked richer and more powerful than
ever before
biden's your guy but if you like the
idea of
more goods made here in the usa more
jobs here
an america refusing to allow the
communists to dominate the globe
then re-electing donald trump is an
american
necessity and that's the angle